why is it useful or interesting to study
mating ideologies at
all it is the foundation of all social
orders we like to think that politics
philosophy all those big subjects of
what it's all about but at the
foundation it's how men and women
reproduce um and upon that everything
else rests so if that falls apart our
societies fall apart
too why does mating need an IDE theology
to sit over it at all it's a it's a
physical activity like why the need for
a story and about what it means and how
we should do it because we've so we've
changed so much from our ancestral
environment um having people commit to
peer bonding for decades and to
providing for Offspring to dedicate the
resources that that requires needs a lot
of coercion we have our biological
impulses but they do not align very well
with modern demands for mating so we
need in addition to that an ideology
that compels people to mate that Co
system uh that makes them think that
it's their duty to uh to pair bond and
have children and the ideology we have
now is compared to previous ideologies
very weak in that regard we're not have
an ideology where this has become
completely voluntary and where it's uh
you can make a good case for why perhaps
you shouldn't have children and that's a
rather unique situation
I like the use of the word coercion
there oh absolutely biological and
cultural coercion it's a huge sacrifice
to reproduce and to to make PE make
enough people do that to a significant
extent now that we also have uh
effective contraception it's really
difficult right so what is it that's
changed primarily in terms of the
demands on mating and resource Supply in
the modern world or even in the
developed world compared with 10,000
50,000 years
ago so much um there are several factors
contraception is huge before you just
needed to want it to copulate and if you
did that enough you'd have children and
then you'd be uh coerced by your
communities to pair bond and take care
of that children that child until it's
uh big enough uh in the modern R we've
now made uh We've deconned culation from
reprodu C and also in these uh
industrialized environments we have
children have become much more expensive
instead of being free labor they're a
huge cost also we have an ideology that
over the past Millennium has become more
and more individualistic so we're not
necessarily convinced that God is
forcing us to have children because that
is the meaning of life uh we now think
that perhaps being single and traveling
and taking care of ourselves is more
important than putting more children out
into the world and in addition um at the
moment we have this a quite uh
significant uncertainty about the future
that also disincentivizes
reproduction what do you think is the
ancestrally typical mating strategy for
humans over time I know that we've had a
few human ancestors and then we kind of
had a little bit of a a movement what
was the journey through uh human
predecessor mating systems you're
thinking the past six million years yeah
yeah give us the story of start six
million years ago we'll take it from
there yeah so we started out like most
vertebrates we we made it promiscuously
uh that means that uh we probably live
together in groups multimale female
multi-male multi-female groups uh where
where individuals were free to uh to
copulate but where reproductive
opportunities were mostly channeled to
high status males and the purpose of
that is that you then distribute uh the
most successful genes within the
population which helps us uh adapt more
quickly to changes Etc
um this is what's most common across
animal groups um but then some species
uh they develop a need for pair bonding
if you can get paternal investment if if
if the males contribute with more than
just genes this can be very beneficial
and this is what happened with uh our
lineage with our with early hominin
about four million years ago where the
ecology changed where it was so
beneficial if if uh if males would
contribute that we then had a transition
we don't know precisely which way the
main hypothesis is that high status
males started keeping Herms and
providing for females and then there's
an alternative hypothesis that is rather
new but quite interesting that this was
a sneaky new strategy for law status
males to be allowed to uh to copulate
and reproduce if they offered
provisioning and protection to females
wow it was like the uh prehistoric
simp
version yeah it's a it's a it's an
interesting hypothesis this is a scholar
he's a theoretical biologist who did
mathematical models and he just couldn't
make it add up for high status uh males
it didn't it it would never make sense
for them to go along with that initial
transition from priscu mating to pair
bonding polygamous pair bonding it made
a lot more sense that those males that
were excluded from mating saw as uh
Offspring needed more uh more help more
provisioning they were they were uh more
dependent on the females that they would
now go in and make the deal that okay I
will provide you with calories and
protection but then you'll let me have
sex with you exclusively so I know that
you offspring are mine and then the
females had to make a trade-off do you
want the good jeans from males that are
only willing to contribute with genes or
do you want a low status male to be
around there and help you get food help
you get protection help you out with the
kid and that would result in kind of
like a resource
acquisition and Supply arms race between
the low status and the high status males
yeah so then this would push so it would
then start because this was so
beneficial because across those four
million years The Offspring development
period doubled uh we just got bigger
heads more helpless when we were born so
it became more and more beneficial to uh
pass on the good jeans and instead get a
mail that would help you out through the
most vulnerable year so through the
pregnancy and then in the beginning
phase of uh when when the child needed
the the provisioning the most yeah and
then this developed until around 2
million years ago when most uh most homo
communities consisted of mostly uh
mostly faithful females and provisioning
males and then a small number of polygon
and a small number of promiscuous maters
because it would never um it would
always in some instances be beneficial
for the female to choose the superior
genes of a high state of smell rather uh
than get a provisioning low state of
smell to to to uh as the father so this
is this is a competing hypothesis
that intuitively it seems
interesting just how rare is male
parental investment in the mammal and
primate
world uh pair bonding yeah or male male
parental investment primarily yeah so uh
I think among mammals it's 10% uh do
pair bonding and among primates it's 29%
but the reason why we think that uh our
lineage were promiscuous maters 6
million years ago is that uh chimpanzees
and bonnos are priscus maters and once a
lineage has evolved pair bonding it is
so beneficial that it's exceptionally
rare that you de evolve from it that's
why we assume that six million years ago
we also had uh promiscuous ancestors
interesting okay so 2 million years what
happens next because we go through some
rapid changes
over from then until now yeah so the
interesting part is that although it
became highly beneficial with pair
bonding there was little pressure on
males for not wanting multiple uh
females to want to make promiscuously
polygamous Le and likewise while it was
beneficial for females to opt for the
provisioning of low status males there
was little pressure on them for not
wanting or Desiring a more successful
mate so what we see what is quite
interesting is that for those 2 million
years the nor was monogamous pair
bonding with some polygamy but um a
really Superior uh forager just couldn't
provide for that many for that many
females but we see that with agriculture
that took off and um resulted in in
pretty extreme uh polygyny at in in the
most um INE equitus environments but
that would have been when was the
Agricultural Revolution 15,000 years ago
something like that 20,000 years ago
around 12 yeah okay so and then it the
the main period was from when around
7,000 years ago all the best
agricultural land had been taken so then
if if you wanted to grow what you had to
do was um was to take land from others
and that created a 2,000-year period
from 7 to 5,000 years ago that had a
pretty bizarre mating regime I don't
know if you're familiar with this no
tell me tell me yeah so I think you've
cited This research I think uh what I
saw your your episode uh with with uh
harinam he cited this study from uh
Carmin at Al in
2015 and he cited the original
hypothesis there where the original
researchers thought that what had
happened 7,000 to 5,000 years ago that
there were just these extreme levels of
polygamy uh that uh the Y chromosome
diversity in our lineage uh was reduced
by 95% meaning that 19 out of 20 males
disappeared while the uh the X
chromosome diversity increased in line
with population growth and if you you
think about it that doesn't make sense
it's just not plausible knowing what we
know about human behavior why would
every so you can imagine that to one
generation a patriarch might castrate
every other male and just impregnate all
the females but that wouldn't make
evolutionary sense for him to do in the
Next Generation when all the all the men
are his sons and this would be an
extremely unstable system and that this
would happen all over the world for
2,000 years it just seems implausible so
in 2018 a new main hypothesis was
established that speaks no more
favorably of our ancestors mating
practices and what probably happened was
that for those 2,000 years all everyone
did uh in order to be able to grow their
tribes because the only way to grow was
to take the fields of your neighbor so
then you had a universal system of
intertribal rating where when when your
kin group was strong enough you would go
to your neighbors kill all the males and
take all the females and all the fields
and that was yours and people kept doing
this for 2,000 years uh until 95% of the
original male DNA was just wiped off the
off the genetic slate so it's yeah 2,000
years of of universal genocide and rape
that's what our ancestors were up to
that's what it seems like and the reason
why we got out of it was that we
invented new stories because up until
5,000 years ago we could only cooperate
with kin and then somebody invented that
some men they are the descendants of
gods so we can submit to them as leaders
and now we can grow our in groups so
instead of just being a king group we
can now be thousands and we can keep
growing and that is of course beneficial
because then we can kill our smaller
neighbors a lot more easily okay so is
this the Inception of having a broader
mating ideology about 5,000 years ago
well what that created was the ability
to create a lot larger societies and it
also this the invention at the time was
slavery before that when you conquered
someone you killed all the males now you
could either turn them into your slaves
or your allies so that was it's it's a
weird thing to think about but if we
think that slavery is is better than
genocide that was actually progress at
some point in our past so when we look
at our ancestors it's they've been yeah
it's it's rather unpleasant group of
people at times yeah when the choice is
between slavery and genocide uh and
you're having to make a value judgment
of which one which one's least bad of
the two uh that's a little bit rough
okay so what given your research looking
at this sort of Journey of mating
ideologies over time what is the
furthest back that you've managed to
find now obviously as you say uh some
kind of
prototypical
religion bonds groups together in a way
that civilizes them beyond what they
normally would and given that so much of
what we were driven by previously the
motivation was very heavily mating
derived or at least mating was one of
the outcomes that we wanted I suppose
you could say that any ideology that CES
is a group together Beyond kin is a
mating ideology but what about when it
becomes a little bit more sort of
specific about what you should what a
man's role is what a woman's role is how
we should combine all of this together
yeah uh that's a good intuition to have
that that is the kind of civilizing
Direction but the ideology mating
ideology didn't change that much from
the period we've described
and up until um the church's disolution
of Europe's tribes about a thousand
years ago we can call that ideology it
is often called heroic love so if you
want to start following the mating
ideologies we've had for through
Antiquity up until the Church of
dissolution of the tribes heroic love
and it's it's uh it's um it's it's a
term that's a little bit problematic
because the point with it was that
during this regime a woman had to always
be ready to submit to the greater
Warrior you didn't necessarily have a
feudal rulers rather State structures
that could protect people people always
up until this time lived in kin groups
and if other groups came and defeated
you then the men would be killed and
enslaved and the women would often be
captured so if women wanted a chance to
survive and protect themselves and their
children they now had to submit to
whomever had killed their father or
their husband so this was this was an
extremely misogynistic rape culture and
this is what
marked you could up up until up until a
thousand years ago and
from from when from the beginning of
Agriculture from that period we talked
earlier where what this this was the
original patriarchy where the male
lineages was matter and women are they
had different way of of conceptualizing
this but women were more like soil where
the patriarchal seed were put so this
way as long as you had these beliefs you
could just capture as many women as as
you as you wanted or were able to and
then keep growing your king group I
suppose as well this heroic love
narrative is uh a useful strategy to
legitimize to the men what they are
doing but also as a coping strategy to
dampen down the discomfort of what the
women are subjected to that if there is
an ideology that sits over the top that
maybe this is the way that mating is
supposed to be done maybe it is
beneficial that your last husband was
killed killed and murdered and that now
you have a new one because he's
evidently the more heroic of the two
therefore it is quite right that you
should go as opposed to the person that
I cared about has just been dismembered
in front of me and now this guy that I
don't know like that's not a
particularly reassuring story whereas
the heroic love narrative uh it's useful
for both sexes in some regards in some
regards but I'm I'm sure it was an
absolute nightmare for these people that
had to go through this and what drove
much of this was uh that these kin
groups generally practiced polygones
mating so uh you'd had Elite individuals
who would hoard women as wives
concubines and sex slaves so for the for
the low value men they didn't have
access to pair bonding or or copulation
so then they were driven throughout
Antiquity to when they had a strong
enough position to go to whichever
whomever their neighbors were and then
kill the men take their stuff and take
their women so this polygamous mating
that marked this period under heroic
love drove a lot of War a lot of social
instability um it it was a quite
enormous change that happened when the
church imposed lifelong monogamy even on
the most Superior of males that that
changed everything when did that
happen well the the Roman Empire uh
played around with mon monogamy but they
were never very serious about it and
then the church Church started imposing
it in the 4th Century but also not very
seriously and then you have a period
That's referred to as the Gregorian
reform at the beginning of the second
Millennium that uh you had a lot of
church councils that work with these
matters because the church wanted to
grab more power over people and if you
can control their mating if you can
control their marriages their sexual
behavior Etc that gives you a lot of
power over powerful men so this is when
they uh dissolved Europe's tribes
through prohibiting cousin marriage
changing rules uh for inheritance and
ownership and then imposing lifelong
monogamy which was a very unusual unique
rather extreme way of thinking of mating
but when you do this this if you want to
understand the origins of the modern
world this was it because this then you
create the sexual egalitarianism this is
how you make parents invest in children
this is where you prepare for growth and
where you start creating a different
more individualistic psychology
different way of thinking your low
immense testosterone so instead of uh
Superior men competing all their life to
acquire more women you get to compete
until you get one and then you have to
uh put your efforts in more in a more
productive Direction how does it help
investment in children why was there not
a massive amount of investment in
children during the heroic mating
era because you would have one father
with several women with a bunch of
children and you would try to maximize
that to the extent that your resources
allowed so you just had a lot less
attention per child and you also didn't
have an ideology where you should
necessarily invest so much in your
children they were more Expendable while
if if then these uh these children are
distributed over more men and you have a
more limited amount of children then you
will be more incentivized to take care
of those children that you do
have what is the reason for the church
or anybody wanting to impose some sort
of rule from a uh civilization design
perspective M what was the advantage or
the change that they were looking to
enact what was the outcome that they
wanted by encouraging lifelong monogamy
well that's really interesting in
hindsight if we like modernity we think
it was brilliant but when we look at the
document that exist at the time it's a
bit of a mystery uh we can suspect
certain things um through dissolving
Europe's tribes and changing uh the
rules for ownership and inheritance the
church by the by the 10th Century had
grabbed 40% of the agricultural land in
Western Europe so that was good you
could see that as a pretty strong
incentive that when you die instead of
your land being passed on to your kin
you now give it to the church so you
don't have to go to hell that's a pretty
strong material incentive and then the
other aspect as I mentioned earlier is
that powerful men that heard a lot of
women if you can impose on them certain
mating structures then you as as the
church if you have to uh acknowledge or
permit their marriages if you can
restrict them then the church get power
over powerful men which is another uh
good understandable material
incentive and then it's it's all just
speculation in terms of what the spir
spiritual ramifications are what they
might have suspected the long-term
consequences would be
but my impression from having studied a
lot of deep cultural changes is that to
some extent things just happen it's it's
just a bunch of people doing a bunch of
things and then it almost magically
sorts itself out and nobody really
understands what's happening when it's
happening and then a 100 years later or
in the modern times historians look back
and kind of try to make sense of what it
was but generally there aren't that many
Grand Architects that have a particular
Vision that they're a able to impulse on
their culture yeah what's that quote
about life happens forward but only
makes sense in reverse and I guess
absolutely history is kind of the same
that we can post talk rationalize what
was it that the church's grand plan was
whereas you know it's much easier to go
for a simple explanation which was they
wanted to control powerful men these
powerful men had lots of resources if
the church slot themselves in between
those men and one of the things that
they want the absolute most which is
women because presumably they couldn't
slot themselves in between the men and
their resources like unless the church
is going to wage a war and say right now
half of this Farm's ours now half of
this house is ours now D D D D D it's a
much more crafty subversive strategy to
be able to somehow make Divine the union
between a man and a woman and then to
for you to be the Arbiter that sits in
between them yeah I can totally see how
it gives you power over powerful men one
thing that hasn't been mentioned so far
which I thought would have come up is uh
sexual redistribution right that if you
have high amounts of inequality within a
sexual system you get young male
syndrome it's not very
good it does this play a role at this
stage or was it just such an accepted
part of the way that the world existed
that that no one was really bothered
about the chaos that came along with it
no in in hindsight we see that it was
hugely beneficial the modern world would
not have happened if if that
redistribution of women hadn't happened
that the church imposed on medieval
Europeans but whether anyone in the
church were able to predict what greater
sexual egalitarianism would have for
consequences for social stability the
potential for growth for peace Etc I
don't know I'd like to think they were
that smart but I kind of doubt it maybe
they noticed this at they went along
that they saw there were beneficial
effects I don't know but yeah the the
end result was was quite impressive but
how it came about who The Architects
were if they really imagined this I'm
kind of doubtful if if if if they
understood the ramifications of what
they were doing okay so uh heroic love
Yeah finishes the church comes in sorry
men no more gang bangs for you what
comes next well this is fascinating and
this speaks again to how how nobody's in
charge so I some of these mating
ideologies I refer to as cultural
dissolvent these are remaining
ideologies upon which you cannot build
social order but they kind of make you
lose faith in the previous ideology so
when courtly love uh was uh created and
disseminated through romances and
ballads from the 12th
century this this was an ideology with
values and Norms that primarily
undermined heroic love so it had an an
exaggeration of the emotional of love as
something that was incredibly strong and
irresistible and that lasted a lifetime
and this was meant to discourage High
status men uh from being polygon that if
you pick just one woman that's going to
last for life and it's going to give you
this special ecstasy that you can't get
if you have more women and also if you
force yourself on a woman so what men
should do and this is what ballads and
romances promote that instead of being
The Greatest Warrior well you also have
to be the greatest Warrior but in
addition to that you have to talk to
women you have to use sophisticated
social skills you have to flirt and
instead of just raping her after you
killed her husband you have to make uh
the woman feel a high uh degree of lust
and love so when she can't help herself
from having sex with you because she she
lust you so much and she loves you so
much that's when you can have sex so you
have all these you have all these values
that's if you just read the Roman as and
ballads and you don't know what they're
reacting against it's kind of hard to
make sense of but when you know the
tenants of heroic love you see that all
these elements of Coury love are
constructed in a sense to undermine
those those strong beliefs from the
previous regime and also it has to do
with a new sociality that when you lived
in kinship groups um you stuck to your
own you were skeptical towards strangers
strangers might want to kill you and
take your stuff but now that we lived in
a feudal Europe where everyone were
supposed to be Christian then we're
supposed to have this openness toward
strangers we're supposed to be friendly
courteous and all these Norms that
defines courtly love is also the way
European Christians were supposed to
treat each other and not just women so
you have all this this brand new type of
sociality that would have never worked
in the kinship system but was crucial
for feudal Europe to have an effective
uh cooperation so as you're becoming
more civilized and as you are uh more
open to new people to being friends with
people stuff like pubs and and Ale
houses and and and things will occur
people will be migrating a little bit
more it's not just my family bonds with
the family next door okay so what about
what is the role of marriage is marriage
widespread at this point is it that you
go through the church and the church
does this thing what about the role of
no sex before marriage and those sorts
of impositions yeah so the transition
was before marriages were private but
with the Gregorian reform they had to be
Church marriages which is also very
important for court to love uh and
what's unique about it's something
called the European marriage pattern
that develops here because this had
never happened before no kin groups had
been dissolved the way the church did it
uh so you got a unique situation in the
west and what happens is that you have
when you can no longer move in with your
kin you have to start accumulating
resour sources so people's marriage age
were pushed up from say from their teens
or early 20s up to the late 20s so you
shortens people reproductive period and
this was crucial because under in
Antiquity we practice what you could
call fourth trimester abortion you might
know this from Vikings you have the
babies you have and then you have a look
at them and then you kill the ones you
can't race so this was how you kept the
population in check and they tended to
kill more females than males so you'd
have a you'd have a low sex ratio um
what they did now because you individual
life became sacred you know have to
restrict people's sexuality they had to
have less sex and one way that they did
this was through this European marriage
pattern where you reproductive period
didn't start until you around 30 years
old that way you didn't have more
children so it was very crucial in this
period that people's sexuality were
restricted otherwise you'd run into
malthusian crisis because you'd have too
many children but what happened
interestingly is after uh the black
death in the mid 14th
century north of Europe lost over in my
country lost over 50% of the population
and around Europe to a third to a half
was lost so in the for in the 1400s you
had what it's called the the sexual
laxness of the 15th century where people
were uh were having a lot more
promiscuous sex sleeping around etc etc
because our environment could afford it
and then when we rebuilt the population
around year 1500 that's when you have
the Reformation that's when you have a
retightening of these sexual Norms
because we couldn't afford anymore
because we refilled up our population
and that's when you get puritanism etc
etc what you were talking about this
sort of window this reproductive window
that um age 30 late 20s was important is
that people were told that they
shouldn't reproduce after 30 or they
weren't permitted to reproduce until 30
so before when you had polygamy and you
lived in kin groups you would have a man
with a lot of resource and he'd marry
every time he feel like it and then he'd
if he'd married a see a woman at 20 and
he'd be 30 or 40 and she'd just start
reproducing right away and the same if
they were younger you would you would
always have a place to live you'd moov
in next to your kin on on your kin
group's land now in feudal Europe you'd
have to accumulate resources to be able
to afford what's called a neolocal
resident you don't live with your family
you live on your own so you'd have to be
on lab men and women would have to be on
labor markets typically in their 20s
until they had accumulated enough
resources to get their own place and
this is what pushed up uh the marriage
age and which so reproductive
reproduction didn't start until
typically in your late 20s for women wow
cuz I you know Game of Thrones as my
greatest window into an accurate
historical representation of what would
have happened in medieval times for
reproduction you know you've got a lot
of essentially child and teen marriages
and women occurring and I certainly know
that some of the aristocracy were doing
this was that
only a behavior or a trend that occurred
in the upper echelons of the the higher
nobility those who had resources so you
see that the very highest the the
highest classes of those that are marked
the the least by these changes to the
Past Millennial of mating moralities
they still uh the very highest status
men they still had lovers on the side
they still had a couple of wives for a
few centuries longer than they were
supposed to so they got away from this
and and the church tried to rest power
from them but it was a bad air they were
still powerful so yeah among the higher
classes you typically would would marry
still when you were around 20 perhaps
right so this is really interesting
obviously we're going to get into it as
we continue down this little Journey
Through Time
but a lot of the conversations at the
moment are for the first time since
records began more women are childless
at 30 than with children at 30 but it
seems to me like if we look only 500 600
years ago you're maybe going to see very
similar sort of fertility patterns
amongst women albe it for very different
reasons than individual choice and and
traveling the world and getting an
education and stuff like that uh but
yeah you're going to see because of the
demands that were placed on their
requirement to accumulate resources both
as men and as women in order to be able
to get started with a family plus you
don't have quite as sophisticated social
safety nets so you do have this
malthusian problem that keeps everything
down so it's like right okay we need to
restrict restrict restrict it's
basically like an entry price into a
nightclub that uh up until the point at
which you can pay the entry price you
can't go to the dance right the dance
being having having kids yeah yeah and
also at this point what was
characteristic of the European marriage
pattern was an exceptionally high
percentage of never married women in a
polygamous system mostly all women are
married under this system it had
extraordinary high percentage of
typically 10% which to us sounds very
low but at the time that was unheard of
so around 10% of women uh never married
during this regime wow okay so we are
currently in courtly love courtly love I
love the fact that it's like uh one of
its primary
design uh justifications was to be a
counterweight to the heroic love
narrative right it it's it's overly uh
restrictive on men compared with what
they had for their value set previous ly
that you must ensure that the woman is
lusting after you then we potentially
add no sex before marriage in as well
that's another that gives you the
Restriction of resources you need to be
able to pay the do you need to make sure
that you've asked for her father's hand
in marriage I'm going to guess that that
comes around some some point around
about this time too which would mean you
know the most difficult gatekeep Arbiter
on the planet you've got to like get his
seal of approval before you can do it
too then you got to go through the
church presumably there's some
assessments that get done by the church
too so yeah all of this not only acting
as a what would end up being useful
sexual redistribution for creating the
foundation of a non-chaotic civilization
moving forward but probably at the
moment the main thing it was trying to
do is let's just stop all of the
powerful men raping everyone like let's
let's just stop that from happening
first and we'll see where we go from
there and the core value here you could
are this is the F West's first sexual
Revolution you could place that around
the year 1200 and the core value here is
female consent so in Antiquity women
were Commodities a marriages were
usually arranged between families again
it was a commercial contract and then
with these
reforms they instituted something called
the double consent so women aren't free
to choose who to marry men aren't free
to choose who to marry but women now
have a chance of refusal so it's still
uh you go from in Antiquity the kin
group was the authority in marriage now
you move to the nuclear family because
that is how you live now so it's still
parents arrange marriage but crucially
women are given leverage through being
allowed to say no so they are still
chused into marriages still not
individual choice but they can say no
and that's that's huge progress right
yeah and that set women on a path of
emancipation that is ongoing the
beginning of female emancipation in the
west was the church's imposition of
female uh the female right to consent in
the first sexual Revolution wow that
changed everything that that's yeah
everything that has happened since was a
result of that first movement okay what
comes after courtly
love well the The Mating ideology that
the society was built on then is
something called companion at love so
this was a very pragmatic ideology and
very different from Court the love in
court the love you and I we are
aristocratic nights and we're going to
travel through Europe to find our one
true love and we're going to fall
incredibly much watch and love and we're
going to live in bless bless Forever
After naturally this was not the reality
for European peasants so the ideology of
companionate Love Is that a man and a
woman shall marry for life through an
arranged marriage whether they like each
other is not or not is not a big deal
and their primary task is to run the
farm as partners to run the farm and
keep their children alive so we're not
going to sleep around we're not going to
divorce and find somebody else we're
just going to huddle down and make sure
that as many children as possible are
alive in the spring so it's a very
pragmatic very unromantic uh ideology
it's about submitting to the needs of
your family and your community and not
giving into emotions or erotic or
romantic impulses so this was the
reality for European peasants from the
beg from the end of from from the from
the first sexual Revolution when the
king groups were dissolved and all the
way up to 1750 which was the West Second
sexual Revolution this was when you this
was a period of companionate Love
arranged marriages pragmatism and then
you had a period before 1500 with sexual
laxness and then a period afterwards
with puritanism uh to restricts people
people's impulses to avoid malthusian
crisis right I was I just about to ask
why the
puritanism
well after this period of sexual laxness
when we had rebuilt population and when
we entered into a period of of
stagnation and stagnant per capita
growth we needed to prevent
Europeans from uh having too many
children to having premarital sex
extramarital sex and the way we have
done this in the west is to villainize
female sexuality women are the sexual
selectors and in order to prevent
extramarital sex from happening or
premarital sex uh the church has in
those instances gone after the women uh
so you'll see in the 1400s female
sexuality is acknowledged and to an
extent celebrated and then when
puritanism comes uh the ideology PE
women do not benefit from sex outside of
marriage uh women who are lustful are
aligned with Satan Etc so it's a way to
oppress women
and to coers them into not having sex
that they shouldn't have which could
then contribute to and crisis so the
choice we face in these situations is
either we kill babies when they are born
the surplus of them or we have to find a
way to prevent people from having
extramarital sex or sex that produces
too much babies and the means we have
tended to use in the west is to uh
demonize female sexuality in those
instances why not try to control male
sexuality it's a really good question if
you look at the differences in male and
female matings psychology and and and
who is in charge on these markets
markets it seems like the more effective
Choice I'm not condoning it but it seems
like the most effective choice to place
the cost on the sexual selectors you
could imagine that men are so driven
that telling men men generally do not
have sexual access to women and to tell
men that they shouldn't have sex number
one it would be harder because they have
a stronger drive for short term uh
relationships but also they that access
isn't there for them while if the women
are the ones who make the decisions in
these in these cases of at least the
voluntary sex then having placing an
enormous burden on women that from our
modern perspective seems totally
misogynistic and unfair it seems that
that would be the more effective way of
doing it yeah because if you're going to
try and restrict men overall but even
now I'm going to guess that there is
still a very large cohort of men more
than 10% who go to their graves without
a family or un married uh therefore
you're you're pointing the finger at the
less reliable potential Mater whereas if
you point the finger at the women it is
more likely that you get more bang for
your book basically on restriction but
presumably there must have been there is
there must be some moralizing around
male sexuality too just probably not
quite the same level of demonization
that women had absolutely so yeah
puritanism also uh demonized promiscuous
men in those stories and the literature
that exists from this period the
greatest villain is are are the favored
villain is often a man who is known to
have slept around so promiscuous men are
also uh put forth as villains and and
and
discouraged
but the the male sexuality is still
acknowledged there's there's something
pathological about a woman who wants to
have sex with someone who isn't her
husband in the Puritan ideology it's if
you want to talk about patriarchal
misogyny the Puritans were really really
bad but then we have to try to then step
aside back and and of course we moralize
on it and say that this is terrible but
then we try to understand why did they
do this what was the function of this
why why did puritanism arise in a period
when it was crucial for the West to
restrain people's sexuality to avoid
malthusian crisis right yeah I
understand if if everybody is dying of
famine and starvation the difference
between the pain of that and the pain of
you shouldn't have sex outside of
marriage it it doesn't yeah I can well
we have to choose if if if we're not
okay with killing babies and Christians
haven't been because of their ideology
while in Antiquity people generally wear
we have to choose we either kill babies
or we strict people's sexuality or we or
we invent contraceptives which we got
around to later what was the reason for
not just killing babies Oh in with
Christianity uh life became sacred so uh
the Christians said that you can't take
any life so once a child so they didn't
they uh criminalized infanticide so
inant infanticide and particularly uh
female selective INF fanticide killing
uh they would typically kill girls cuz
they were costlier depending a little
bit on the on the context but yeah so
the practice of infanticide was just
cracked out on really hard by the
Christians because it went against their
belief of every life being sacred yeah
okay well that's interesting that the
church's Doctrine is uh both like giveth
and taketh away here that they have made
their own bed okay we say that in
fanticide isn't good we value human life
oh Downstream from that we now have
this other problem which is being able
to control populations so that we don't
get some fisherian runaway like
malthusian also not good okay
so I mean one other thing that that's
kind of I guess interesting to add here
is that the Middle Ages didn't finish
until the 1500s right we're still in the
Middle Ages from pretty much fall of
Rome 500 to 1500s is like that's it's
just one big long medieval like
hodg Podge right then we get to you said
1750 ish MH y y I mean you know we're
talking now only 250 years ago and it
feels like there is an awful lot of
ground to cover uh in terms of sexual
ideology so what what happened 1750 so
that's the West Second sexual Revolution
this was one of individual choice so
what we don't think about in the west
this is It's a evolutionary psychologist
called M apost has done great work on
this how throughout human history we've
had arranged marriage marriages he makes
the case that the human species is the
only species on the planet where men
select other men for reproduction this
has always been the case and during
agriculture it was more the kin group uh
and then um after the the first sexual
Revolution this was more a matter for
the nuclear family meaning the patriarch
the father of the family so human men
and women this is important to
understand to understand the present day
mating dysfunction we didn't not evolve
under regimes of individual choice we
generally we had an influence but we
generally didn't pick and attract our
own mates we were given mates by our
families and communities so our in our
somewhat weak ability or many people's
weak ability to flirt and attract
Partners attract short longterm
Partners this is thought of as as a form
of mismatch due to individuals not
having that responsibility in the past
that the in the west started getting
from 750 so what happened with the
dissolution of Europe's tribes is that
our psychology changed fundamentally
this was the biggest change in
introduction of Agriculture so we were
put on a journey then say for 8 900
years ago toward ever greater
individualization more and more and more
and more non-stop still ongoing and it's
not going to stop for a while and by by
the 18th
century Europeans started more and more
thinking that should be entitled to make
the wrong decisions in terms of mating
copulation and pair bonding and what
facilitated this materially is that you
had this commercial revolution where
more and more people worked as servants
in their youth for uh for cash payments
so to accumulate these resources to be
able to marry people moved further and
further away from
family and uh they were paid in cash and
this was the material foundation for the
West Second sexual Revolution so among
Ong these young
proletarians around 1750 this European
marriage pattern just burst and people
started having a lot more sex pre uh
before marriage uh on the side also so
you had this enormous growth in in
sexual activity especially among young
people that had enormous
consequences and and this continued so
it wasn't like everybody started writing
away making their own decisions but it
it started among these young wage Jers
and then over the centuries that spread
and it um and and the dam completely
burst with a third sexual revolution in
the
1960s I love the idea that
flirting is basically uh like an
evolutionary anomaly that if you were to
have the ability ancestrally if if if
you come from a long line of flirters
and your great great great great great
granddaddy he was a flirter and the
granddaddy before it's like why like why
you know previously you would have just
been taking what you wanted then after
that you would have been told what you
wanted then after that your dad would
have told you what you wanted and then
only 250 years ago would you have
actually chosen what you wanted yeah
Leif caner who whom you know he makes
this this interesting case h today to Be
an Effective F if you're a really
good-looking guy and you're really
Charming a good flirter and you're
short-term oriented you're going to have
a lot of mating
success in the olden
days there would be a greater there
would be a significant chance that you
would get snuffed out if if you uh if
you were a solid guy who created
alliances worked hard led a family you
would be chosen for reproduction by
other men and given to their daughters
if you were just this good-look Adonis
who like to sleep around you probably
going to get K killed by the by the men
in the king group of your latest elicit
Affair oh yeah because you're threat in
some regard even if even if you don't
get rumbled by the king group of the men
of the woman that you just managed to
seduce outside of her marriage and
outside of your own marriage even if you
don't get caught by the Scruff of the
neck by them you're just going to create
a ambient sense of concern and envy and
mistrust because oh we know that mads
we've got to be careful about him like
he's got the he's got the charm
like you know I've heard rumors and it
almost becomes I guess a to some degree
a little bit like the witch trials that
you have this it's not quite original
sin but it's something inbuilt that will
cause other men to feel uh envy and
jealousy and weigh rather than
understand and turn it Inward and work
out what it is that's lacking in them
that makes them envious of this person
it's way easier to just moralize about
the person that's the outg group now and
say let's kill him and also
times were really tough a lot of the
time you needed a really solid guy
willing to work really hard do whatever
he can to provide for his wife and
children to keep them alive if you're
just this charming hottie who likes to
uh chat up women around the farm it's
that does that did not generally promote
a good genetic Legacy times the demands
of the times were just different times
were very different than they are today
are you saying that we are the
descendants of the least charismatic
least good-looking least flutatious men
that existed well it depends on the
ecology but yeah generally our ancestors
have not been lotharios that's uh that's
only recently where that has been very
beneficial right so we get to 1750
people are now able to make their own
decisions uh actually one question there
how is it that the church loses control
does the church feel like it is losing
control does it try to claw it back in
any regard I know that uh in the time of
Charles Darwin uh you know Victorian
England we had an awful lot of sort of
sexual puritanism there I think uh the
year of the year of Darwin's birth the
total number of British divorces was
eight yeah not thousands not hundreds
eight yeah no what happens 1750 is
really interesting because there's a
counter reaction so we have what we call
the Romantic Century from 1750 to 1850
so I'm sure with your imagination you
can imagine what happened when this Dam
burst in 1750 now we're going to start
sleeping around whoops we haven't
invented the contraceptive pill yet
what's going to happen so what happens
is you have an enormous increase in
illegitimate birth across Europe it
doubles triples quadruples so what you
typically have are all these uh low
lower class women who now can make their
own decisions in terms of culation and
pair
bonding and their ancestors no
experience with this so we didn't evolve
to uh see through the intentions of men
wouldn't invol evolve uh to assess our M
our own mate value precisely so what
would happen that you would have a lot
of high status men or at least higher
status men say uh sons of farmers uh
Urban men who would then go after the
daughters of crafters and other at the
lower rungs of society and they would
say I love you and I'm going to marry
you and let's have sex and they would do
that and when she got pregnant they
would leave her so in in Denmark Norway
up until till 7:30
7:34 uh if you had sex sty was a defacto
marriage contract and then what we see
in the beginning of the 1700s there's a
huge increase in women taking men to
court for having had sex with them but
at marrying them so they end that law in
1734 so after that if you get pregnant
you're not entitled to marry the guy you
had sex with so from 1750 you get this
enormous increase in illegitimate birth
at the worst in Sweden and in in
Stockholm 50% of child births were by
unwed mothers lower in rural areas in
Paris you see an enormous increase
theand abandoned children so in the in
the late
1700s there was an ideology which I also
consider as a cultural disant because
you couldn't build a social order on it
and this was Liberty in love so this is
the kind of kasanova ideology where
you're supposed to just enjoy sex for
the sake of sex you're supposed to sleep
around follow your lusts and this was an
ideology that spread from the French
court and then throughout Europe and it
reached uh Scandinavia around 1770 so
you had this period where you have
certain eccentric Muse where people
advocated let's just sleep around let's
just have a hell of a good time let's
just party and this created this
enormous burden on women because women
were left with the burden of child care
when these Libertines left them once
they got pregnant so typically High
status men took advantage of of of
impoverished women and then just abandon
them and this is what laid a foundation
for the Romantic ideology of the early
1800s so Liberty love undermine
companionate love where where you're
just supposed to be pragmatic and double
down take care of your family and
Liberty love said no let's just have fun
and then when the social Ramic
ramification of that uh came manifested
themselves the counter reaction was
romantic love which did the same as
Puritan love had done where you again so
Liberty love celebrated female sexuality
let's just have sex romantic love said
no women have no benefit from sex
outside of marriage we're all going to
have to stop doing this and similar to
courtly love it exaggerated the
emotional love as something incredibly
strong and something that lasted for
life so from then on men and women were
only supposed to have sex within the
confines of marriage and you should be
married forever and this started having
an effect around 1850 and then across
the West the legitimacy rate started
plummeting so you see this counter
reaction first you dissolve companionate
love then you see the effects of all
this priscy and then in order to reduce
the suffering of the women that this
affects you have a counteract or
romantic love where you then become more
purtin again and then you see the effect
of that in the statistics right you
reprioritize the emotional connection
the Romantic connection between the man
and the woman and what that does is that
again creates a dampener on The
Libertine Casanova guy lothario that's
just okay yeah that's so interesting I
what I'm seeing here is this this
flip-flop
between what seems in sometimes uh human
nature kind of just bursts through the
cracks it kind of grows and grows and
grows enough and then it splits through
that um there is innate desires that
people have uh you're also responding to
the local resources so I'm going to
guess that around about 1750 uh
Agriculture and green houses and
like that meant that the ability to get
an amount of food and an amount of
living out of a square foot of land
would have increased pretty dramatically
which means that this malthusian
problems not okay right so we can't
really we we're no longer Limited in
terms of food what's the next thing that
we can use they're having sex with
each other uh uh say that it's all about
romance say that it's all about the the
over prioritize the importance of
emotional connection because that that
allows us to create but we' we've also
lost at least a little bit here we've
lost the um Church's moralization or at
least it sounds like we've lost the
church's moralization of the active love
yeah and the 1800s this was the time of
the Enlightenment this what was about
individual rights uh empowering
individuals not oppressing them uh
letting them make their own choices
personal agency etc etc and this was was
also at the dawn of the Industrial
Revolution so when this uh um European
marriage pattern burst around 1750 we
were very fortunate for two reasons
because we now experienced a population
explosion in going ahead that is still
ongoing well I take that back it's not
ongoing anymore uh but we had we got
this moving into this period tremendous
economic growth that helped us take care
of the population explosion and also we
offloaded an enormous part of our
population to America and other uh
Colonial territories otherwise we would
have faced dire trouble in the west um
as a as a as the change of our mating
practices and also with the reduction in
mortality from other causes okay then
perhaps the shortest most acute change
when it comes to human reproductive
history the introduction of reliable
contraception well yeah so one of the
aspects of ROM rantic love is that you
have gender inequality you conceptualize
men and women as complimentary that uh
people are born as incomplete halves and
then to become whole you have to find uh
your true love you have to bond with her
and then you individualize and you
become a whole human so this means that
the man is supposed to go out and work
and the woman is supposed to stay home
and take care of the domestic Arena so
they're conceptualized as equal but
complimentary but in reality this drove
Stark inequality
so the next mating ideology we move to
which is the one we believe in today
it's called confluent love which is a
mating ideology of gender equality of
convenience reward and
self-realization and this ideology arose
quite a while ago it was first
introduced into Scandinavian literature
in
1839 but it had existed in the in the
west somewhat earlier so people were
thinking about this that we should get
true equality that men and women should
be the same and have the same
opportunities and that we should be able
to have sex outside of marriage and
sleep around but the environment wasn't
prepared for that like you mentioned
this couldn't really be implemented
until we invented effective
contraception otherwise this kind of
mating would have placed too far too
strong of a burden of women so we see
this discussion in Western culture from
say around
1830 and then with the Darian Revolution
we start thinking okay so with romantic
love we thought obviously this is what
God wanted us to do that we have this
impulses that you also mentioned that's
just a test from God to see if we
deserve to go to heaven so that we want
to have sex and that we want to divorce
that's just a test and also at the
beginning of our conversation you asked
why do we need these ideologies and this
is precisely why because we have these
biological impulses to culate and our
our um our love cycle probably evolved
to last around 3 to four years which was
the mating cycle of foragers so with
agriculture we needed to commit to
lifelong monogamy because in case of
divorce you can't split up the fields
and and bring your part of the farm
somewhere else so we were kind of stuck
in these marriages that had to last many
many more decades than what we evolved
for so then you need these ideologies to
make us fight these urges that we have
to sleep around to to have uh we evolve
for serial monogamy or serial pair
bonding to fight that because the the
cultural environment and then a modern
environment just required something else
for us so then we used religion we say
that this is what God wants but then
with the Darian Revolution we start
thinking well if we're animals we too
then these impulses we have they're not
moral tests this is our nature so we
started exploring what human mating
nature is and this was a very uh strong
literary movement in Scandinavia in the
late 1800s and then also through the
1900s through literature we started
exploring how could we make differently
but what's really interesting is that
the Romantic regime did not Peak until
after World War II so we we experienced
something that was really unexpected
because in the in the 1910s and 20s we
were moving away from romantic love we
wanted female equality we were moving
toward confluent love but then after
World War II we we had this enormous
economic prosperities that allowed us to
implement the Romantic Utopia which is
the bread winner housewife model so
suddenly marriage in the west became
near Universal almost everyone married
they married young and now we got to
experience that the Romantic Utopia a
couple of shortcomings number one life
does love generally doesn't last a
lifetime and the Utopia at staying at
home wasn't that great for all women so
this and you had this in the 1950s in
the beginning of the 1960s and then you
have the social revolution of the 1960s
and you could say as symbol symbolically
that the the Breakthrough of confident
love was in in
1968 and then you start seeing in the
beginning of the 70s around the mid 70s
across the West you see in the
statistics that this modern M marriage
pattern that we've had and that peaked
after World War II it just thegrates
divorce Peaks remarriage goes down
people marry later you have a lot more
uh casual sex outside of marriage people
start having sex earlier and you just
see this complete change in the Western
marriage pattern from the 1970s and on
and this is the and this is this has
mostly just gone in One Direction and
this is the mating regime that we live
under now which has been uh accentuated
through dating apps through increased
Prosperity through all that has happened
in the past 40 50 years when you say
confluent love am I right in thinking
that what that means is our
Union uh works and continues to make
sense for as long as you are useful to
me and I'm useful to you yeah so
romantic love emerge for life that's the
only way to behold people confident love
we come together either for an
opportunistic short-term relationship
casual sex or for a romantic
relationship for as long as we have
emotions for each other or we benefit in
another way and then we move on to
singledom or another relationship so
we're not meant for each other for Life
only for as long as we want to so it's
this Confluence of people coming
together and meeting and moving on right
so now that we've arrived pretty much
close to the modern era how do
you how do you think of sort of modern
dating dysfunction demographic collapse
all of that stuff is that you know from
1200 was that just the first Domino gets
flicked and it's an inevitable kind of
all the way along how how do you
conceptualize this Al together yeah I I
wouldn't use the word inevitable but I I
I completely agree with with your
intentions behind that yeah that is what
set it in motion we've always had
arranged marriages and lived in King
groups and then more strictly under
agriculture but still and then we was
set on this path toward individual
Choice never great
individualism and then it's
just to have like we talked about in the
very
beginning it's hard to convince people
to take upon themselves the burden of
Decades of pair bonding with the same
person and providing for
Offspring and when you have a strong
individualistic culture and a mating
ideology assess that this is optional
that you don't necessarily have to do
that we're facing an evolution that is
quite predictable and as you've talked
about on many of your podcasts it seems
to be going a direction where We've ran
out of tools there's not much we could
do we had in the in the
1930s uh decline in fertility also which
we countered
then it the numbers I've seen in
Scandinavia went down to 1.8 which was
seen as a catastrophe and then we
counted through effectuating social
democracy we we we uh made it materially
easier to have children through Social
Democratic welfare all that has played
out now that's that's no longer an
option in in Norway now
uh a typical the average woman she
receives more than $1.2 million more
from the state than she pays in taxes
while men pay more in taxes than they
receive and when even that can't uh
motivate uh reproduction at at at
replacement levels in and this is Norway
is the richest country in the world and
we have the best welfare system and when
even that kind of money transfer can't
uh facilitate reproduction there's very
little other countries can do so up
until 2010 Scandinavia was an anomaly
across the West fertil has declined for
a long time so we thought that the
answer or many thought that the answer
was that other countri had to beavia
they needed gender equality because
we're the most gender equal region and
they needed generous welfare and now in
the past decade the Norwegian forer rate
dropped from in the 2010 from 2.0 to 1.5
and now it's dropped down to
1.4 and that's with each woman on
average being transferred $1.2 million
over a lifetime that's a lot of money
there's econ economic incentives no
longer cease to work so we kind of know
that for other countries too that would
only be a short-term Sol solution that
would be countered by other forces that
are more powerful so if we think it's a
good idea to still making uh to still
make people and avoid a demographic
collapse it's very difficult to see what
kind of means we can effectuate that
would have it a substantial effect that
could turn this around what are the
forces that are driving the decrease in
uh fertility rights at the
moment well the larger forces
uh the material ones is urbanization
like we've talked about before and like
many others have talked about how
there's been when we lived as
agriculturalist having children with
free labor and now they're just huge
expenses so that is that is one
issue um the other one is ideological
that we no long with romantic love the
meaning of life was to merge with your
partner and have a bunch of
children with with confluent love it's
about
self-realization uh reward
convenience when we have those beliefs
it's just we're just less incentivized
to take upon ourselves these burdens so
also mentioned Fair of the
future um and then you have what I've
researched a bit is what happens with
our mate preferences in this new
environment of the past decades how um
on one side when you make uh as in
Scandinavia when you have gender
equality and you have generous welfare
it makes it maturely easier to have
children so that counts in a positive
direction but it also disincentivizes
women from peir bonding with men of
similar mate value so that's another
aspect of these ideologies and mating
regimes that it's it's really difficult
to make women mate with men with with
low mate value unless they have to
unless they are materially dependent on
it or coerced to do so by their society
we have two attraction systems we have
the original one that we talked about
when we started 6 million years ago were
promiscuous maters and this is a very
discriminatory uh uh system for women
where they're supposed to only be uh
promiscuously attracted by the very most
attractive men maybe this is somewhere
between five and 20% of men probably
closer to five and then five four
million years ago we evolved this other
system to facilitate pair bonding which
is a much more in a sense democratic
system where a muchar larger proportion
of men is able to trigger their love
mechanism that makes that motivates a
woman to mate with them but we see that
when women don't have to they uh become
Chooser and they uh direct their efforts
at men with higher mate value than what
they have themselves and that makes it
harder to pair up more people within a
community which then will have adverse
effects on the fertility right and when
women are not financially or resol ful
beholden to their partner in order to be
able to keep them ticking over because
they have no job they have no education
or they have limited socioeconomic
opportunities uh I need to stay with my
partner because the alternative is that
me and potentially 1 2 3 four five
children are out on the street so we
basically kind of like a a financial
prisoner in some regards to their
husband and now that women don't need
that anymore the gloves are yeah and and
from from Modern ideology and I'm I'm
sure both you and I feel this way this
is great for women women aren't
dependent on being with a man they are
they are independent they have their own
money their own economy and they can
make their own choices and they can
choose uh to direct their efforts and
compete harder for the high value men
instead of settling for someone with a
similar value as themselves but then the
consequence of that is that we have uh
uh we have a very high increase in
singledom we have a decline in fertility
and it also affects people's well-being
people generally Express a desire to be
pair bonded and they want to they want
to be together with someone that's kind
of what we've been doing the last four
million years and then when people react
to different incentives in the modern
environment we see that quite a few of
those work counter to people being able
to find each other and create
relationships yeah I looked at a study a
pretty what looked like significant
assessment that said gender inequality
specifically when it comes to finances
is correlated with both male and female
satis action in relationships which is a
really if you want to talk about like
unfortunate uh uncomfortable U
realizations that if you as a man are
able to whether by coercion or
restriction or capacity or whatever out
earn your female partner and if the
breaks are put on your female partner
she's happier and you're happier on
average yeah I know if if there's so
many depressive statistics if you want
to look at what actually get the
fertility rate up you have to if what
would really work is to and we don't
want any of this we have to get rid of
gender equality get rid of prosperity uh
domestic violence works there's tons of
stuff that work to uh to make women
submit to being in the relationship that
they otherwise would want to be in yeah
to go stop being uh whatever it is cost
benefiting to um uh what's it called
when the man there's two types of mate
guarding right uh whatever the second
one is I know what you mean yes yeah so
no there's if you look at what actually
would work to get the fertility rate up
these are very dystopic choices we have
there there are there are pretty much
nothing that we in the west would be
ideologically disposed to doing that
could have a significant positive effect
all those mechanisms that we know would
have an effect would be go against what
we believe in so we're in a very
difficult situation one thing that has
kind of been running through my mind as
you've told us this tale is especially
when you look at the modern world which
still has an awful lot of the carryover
I think from the Romantic Era uh of you
know moralizing around faithfulness uh
Chastity uh loyalty to your partner
stuff like
that it it seems
so insane that we've managed to get
ourselves to a place where our evolved
mating psychology and the structures
that we had for so so so long have just
become perverted and perturbed and
ruined and repurposed and countered and
so on and so forth and we are you we
talk about evolutionary mismatch an
awful lot everybody knows what that is
but this seems to be like it's a a
sedimentary rock of evolutionary
mismatch right you know you've got the
the culture from before and and the
counterculture to that culture and then
you've got new technology reproductive
technology what about the fact that
we're all individuals female
socioeconomic access and egalitarianism
that's new like how do we work
that out um we're no longer living in
pan generational houses our kin doesn't
give us any advice about the world is
moving so quickly that our parents
advice basically doesn't even work for
the new generation because they don't
understand what does it mean to be
dating on Tinder and then we've still
got all of these vestigal mating systems
from before so it really doesn't
surprise me you know when you take a
really Global look at human mating
psychology plus the modern world plus
the journey that our psychology has been
dragged through really over the last few
Millennium it's really not surprising
that people are are struggling at the
moment yeah on top of that dating apps
are a little over a decade old and we
haven't figured that out at all and and
the incentives that drive those apps and
those who create them
goes so counter to people's to people's
needs and desires and and how our
psychology functions it's we've put
oursel in a situation where there's like
you say there's so much novelty on top
of novelty that men and women don't even
understand what their mate preferences
are and how those are being influenced
by the social order and the technology
they use to meet people so we're just
we're following these six million year
old impulses which are the strongest one
and they're overriding impulses that are
four million years old not even to think
about the newer ones that we've
developed and in all of this we're in
this uniquely new mating regime of
individual choice that we have not
evolved for at all so it's when you look
back and you think why was it that say
perhaps through the the two million year
history of the Ginos homo if if it is
the case in fact that we always had
parental Choice through that is it
because everybody discovered that
individual Choice doesn't add up I mean
there's no way the West is going to go
away from that and I certainly wouldn't
Advocate it but if no one else managed
to figure that out how sure are we that
that that this is going to work for us
and yeah if if you extrapolate from
today if with this decline in
fertility maybe I mean we're certainly
going to write out this experiment I
don't see us changing any any anyway uh
but there are there are peoples around
the world who aren't in who aren't
pursuing that regime that are showing
different numbers and it's I mean we
love our ideology we think it's Superior
to everybody else's ideology that's just
how humans work but uh but there's
there's one F I mean you could say
everything is relative but there's one
thing that isn't relative that's an
evolutionary iron law no matter what
your ideology is if that ideology causes
you to stop reproducing that ideology
will cease to matter you will disappear
yeah I mean this was one of the most
interesting takeaways I've had from a
lot of conversations about demographic
collapse and population decline which
is um ideology political leaning your
worldview at large your openness your
conscientiousness all the rest of those
things are highly heritable highly
heritable your political ideology is
very highly heritable right as is the
rest of your psychology so if
you are somebody that is part of a
particular political movement that
either doesn't promote or actively
discriminates against
reproduction you are a Dying Breed
because your children would have more
likely been like you and look at the
groups that are reproducing like
something tells me that conservative
ashkanazi Jews are not going to have
that much of a fertility problem right
something tells me that Mormons or that
uh some sects of Christianity I know
that some are down but some sects of
Christianity also going to be fine so
what do you look at over a long enough
time Horizon you actually look at this
sort of almost like full circle loop
back around to a much more not
necessarily puritanical but like a
religious sacred
view of what this is and remember if you
are somebody that's conservative or
somebody that's religious the likelihood
that your children are going to be that
way is it's absolutely not predetermined
but they are predisposed right so you
end up with this sort of ever increasing
cycle of this so there was there's an
argument to be made I think that uh you
know like anti-natal climate
concerned
liberalism is not long for this world
right it's not to say that you can't
have a a sufficiently compelling
ideology that comes around in 50 years
time and reconverts a bunch of Seventh
Generation conservatives or whatever uh
but yeah you will end up with less uh
demographic uh political variety over
time if you have this because the
selection effect occurs within
particular cohorts within very
particular stru and it presses down very
hard on them and the other ones are just
like what demographic collapse I'm fine
yeah well we also have some tremendous
novelty coming up which we have to bear
in
mind I predict that the West will have a
fourth sexual Revolution uh coinciding
with the fourth Industrial Revolution
what will happen when we start uh being
able to create babies outside of of
women's wombs when we'll be able to Gene
edit etc etc and we we get AI robot
lovers and and and spouses etc etc
there's going to be such tremendous
technological novelty that's going to
change society that it's almost
inconceivable that this will not have a
tremendous effect also on mating so if
we extrapolate into the future without
taking that into account yes then the
West as it function now would just made
itself out of existence and other groups
would take over who have higher
fertility but that doesn't seem to be
the future we are facing there's there
will be so much change in the decades
ahead that it's very difficult to
imagine how mating will be in the future
but I I I think that Revolution will be
will be so large that it will
fundamentally change that aspect like we
talked about in the beginning the
foundation every social order is mating
so then the question is how will these
new technologies affect how we mate and
how will that create a new foundation
for a new form of
society yeah yeah I I suppose we are
living maybe in the last death throws of
something that even slightly resembles
an ancestral mating system you know as
soon as as soon as you have external
wombs as soon as you have ai companions
that can give you better than real life
love uh yeah the Pod hiiki Mori problem
gets sorted but it only gets sorted from
the individual's perspective from the
population perspective it's not sorted
at all but then if you can counter that
with artificial WBS but then who is it
that you're choosing like whose genes
are you choosing to do this and if you
have you know embryo selection which is
already online you know embryo selection
for IQ for externalizing behavior for
depression for anxiety for autism you
already have this and then if you can
get into Gene editing and then if you
can get into ivg it's like okay here's
like a here's a section of the skin from
my arm go forth and make 1 million Chris
Williamson's like I Jesus Christ but
yeah I
it's maybe we are maybe this is uh a
uniquely interesting time but I wonder
whether I wonder whether some of the
interventions that we are uh thinking
about at the moment you know uh Hungary
you have one kid and you do this thing
and you have two kids and you get more
taxes off and you have three kids and
you don't pay taxes for life or no way
and the way that you guys 1.2 million
that you give to women and you know we
need to get people to do CBT to overcome
approach anxiety and all of the rest of
it I wonder whether ultimately all of
those things are going to be in vain
within the space of five decades because
the technology is just going to rip out
anything that we try to construct using
like like cultural technology
ideological movement oh Hollywood why
don't we get Hollywood to like put dads
that are competent again at the front
and we shouldn't have Homer Simpson and
Peter Griffin as the lead we should have
like you know like a good standup Family
Guy and you're like yeah but if in five
decades it's artificial wombs and sex
robots all the way
down what does any what do any of those
interventions really matter that's not
to say that making the well-being and
flourishing of people who live right now
isn't nothing but over a long enough
time Horizon they all just get like
someone shakes the eter sketch and just
deletes all mating
history yeah no um when you look at the
history of Western mating it's it's I
don't fear very much that we'll be
returning to a uh a handmaid's tail
Puritan kind of female oppressing regime
I think we're going to move forward and
that we will experience a novelty at a
level that we it's very difficult for us
to imagine today uh so yeah it's we can
talk about it we can speculate
but when we are at this side of these
big revolutions as we seem to be now
before we go into it and see how
dramatically the world would change and
this time a lot more rapidly than would
previous such
revolutions it's all we can do is is
mostly hold on like I don't believe that
there I don't I I love what you're doing
with your podcast but I people can't get
informed and that's good but that
somehow we're going to figure something
out make a plan and then effectuate it
and and stop the demographic collapse
that doesn't seem to be how the world
Works um it's just going to be a
whirlwind a hurricane of change yeah and
then at the end of it I think it would
be really cool if we still have a bunch
of humans around I'm kind of I'm a
little bit specious that way but things
can play out in a matter of ways that
are are just impossible to predict on
this side of the singularity yeah yeah
it's the technological change the size
of the wall that occurs is so high that
it's very difficult to have something
permeate through it and yeah I totally
agree one of the other things that you
do your other Wing one of your other
many other wings uh an evolutionary lens
on well-being and obviously we've had a
lot of conversations recently about uh
incels and I only learned this from you
in sings as well involuntary Singletons
um given your evolutionary lens
background and your studies into
well-being what are you making of the
general generalized anxiety uh
depressive States you whatever it is uh
50% % of girls aged 12 to 16 have
regular or persistent feelings of
hopelessness you know you've got guys
with testosterone in the toilet the
single biggest threat to a man under the
age of 50 is his own hands you know in
terms of suicidality all this sort of
stuff um what how do you sort of
conceptualize all of this together from
a well-being perspective why are the
incels and the in syns and everybody
else so unhappy yeah I know that's
that's something I think we should
really be concerned with
uh we we should try to change the world
and make a better world but as as we
spoken about it's our ability to effect
change that way is somewhat limited but
when we're going through these deep
changes as we are now and we have before
people will face despair they will lose
faith in the story that has United us we
haven't yet found tomorrow's ideology
that would give us the answers and the
comfort and lessen our anxiety so we
really should be sympathetic towards
each other and that pain that people are
suffering when we go through these
changes cuz these changes are very hard
on humans we like stable periods when we
know when we convinced theel that we
know what truth is so when you look at
incels and instincts you should expect
them that they should be miserable from
an evolutionary perspective uh happiness
is a reward you experience when you
solve adaptiv adaptively relevant
problems and nothing is more Central to
adaptivity than reproduction so if
you're not succeeding on short or
long-term mating markets if you're not
able to pair bond your well-being system
should go into high alert and let you
know that your strategies are failing so
when men become depressed and despondent
from not succeeding on the short-term
market and women become depressed and
despondent because they know it is on
Modern dating markets they have
unlimited access to sex with higher
value men but none of these men are
willing to pair bond with them that is
supposed to give you a depression that's
your that's your organism telling you
that you're failing so instead of
villainizing uh incel men or making fun
of insing women we should try to spread
a better understanding and here your
podcast is valuable people need to
understand the different mate
preferences that men and women have they
should understand the different power
dynamics and short and long-term mating
and see how today's mating particularly
with dating apps is creating a
stratification that is creating
dysfunction for almost all groups of
society or at least potentially so a
better understanding of what is going on
might not help us steer this this clown
car into safe Shores but it might help
us sympathize more more with each
other's plights especially uh between
men and women because men and women have
such different challenges in today's
dating economy and if we kind of if men
impose male mate preferences in their
analysis of how women are doing and
opposite we just don't understand each
other and that just creates bigger
dysfunction poorer communication and
people get even more miserable how much
of the current unhappiness do you think
should be laid at the feet of mating and
dating problems because there's lots of
other things going on social media and
comparison and you know
intergenerational competition Theory
where we are the first generation that's
not done better than our parents and so
on and so forth but how much of this do
you think ultimately is just post talk
rationalization that I can't find a mate
and romance seems to be dead and my
partner might leave me at any point if
the Confluence no longer works it's a
good question and I haven't seen any
statistics that are able to get at it it
doesn't show up there so we we'll have
to speculate so in Norway now we have
something called called a men's panel
it's a it's a it's a big research
project or more of a council that
they're trying to figure out why men are
falling behind and you see this around
the world in the UK they're talking
about having a a men's Minister it's
been suggested Etc
and uh I know at least for the nor this
this Norwegian effort which by the way
is the third in 15 years to try to
figure this out they haven't figured it
out anything previously it's not even
within their mandate to look at uh
mating marginalization and the
stratification that is happening on
Modern dating Market it's just a thing
that it feels inappropriate to talk
about but especially when it comes to
men
what one of the Prime functions of
having two Sexes to have uh sexual
reproduction is the sexual selection
where women select which men get to get
to breed
so males of all species have been under
enormous pressure to succeed in this
regard that is the motivation that is
their their reason of being at the
deepest M most foundational level so we
have reason to think that now that more
and more men are being excluded from
short and long-term mating when they're
being uh selected Away by women because
they are not valuable in the modern
environment we would predict that these
men would do poor and poor they would
not be motivated to put in the effort
because they have a sense of how hope it
might not be a conscious sense but that
drive that men would have in other times
when they had a better Prospect of
acquiring a mate when that disappears we
should expect male marginalization also
in other areas of life and Society so
that we're not looking at that is
unfortunate cuz we would expect that to
be the foundational level upon which
this other males uh attaches to but I
haven't seen any statistics or research
that allows me to assign a proportion of
unhappiness to men being to more men
being selected away from mating so um I
don't I don't think that is possible I
think it's more a foundational aspect
that it's really difficult to get
at yeah man I mean the fact that we're
not tearing each other apart uh I
suppose you know know when you look at
the sadness and and the depression and
the hopelessness and stuff like that and
a more obvious question would be how
wouldn't we all feel like this you know
so much change and
and our adaptability is fundamentally
one of the things that Humanity has as
its you know Keystone Advantage but
there's a limit you know dear God
there's a limit to how quickly the world
can change and we can hold on for dear
life uh and um yeah I
think it's so it's such a slippery slope
right because as soon as you say well
the world is changing very quickly and
oh we're not adapted for technology like
the victimhood mindset just immediately
seeps in everything is out of my control
locus of control gets externalized
that's associated with more depression
therefore people don't feel like they
can enact any change they're no longer
agentic or Sovereign individuals blah
blah blah you're like oh my God so yeah
like trying to thread this needle
between like compassion and
encouragement is a really difficult one
and I mean you know all of this work on
well-being that you're doing through an
evolutionary lens must it must feel like
human well-being is kind of being just
pulled apart um yeah and like you said
um young women are doing worse than
young men and and what we see in the
research that we're doing now is that
this big change in World being at least
in Norway and Norway is doing better
than most other countries we we're doing
as we're such a success we've been such
a successful country in the past decades
so we were at the top of of the world
happiness report but we now slid down
several spots and this seems to be
entirely because of this drastic
reduction in well-being among young
people 15 to 24 uh and and we've we've
made interviews with them there there's
quantitative service of them and we're
doing qualitative interviews and young
people are feeling bad and you have many
aspects and and social media seems to
facilitate some of these these
mechanisms that drive ill
beinging uh the economy Fair of the
future you have all kinds of things that
are weighing on young people and it's
very difficult to sort them and see what
is what but I think like you that the
main driver now is that we we are as a
civilization in such a transformative
time it seems that we're moving out of
this this modern Narrative of believing
in Liberal humanism that's peaked in the
1990s and that we in the in the last
decade have lost more and more faith in
we don't know why we should cooperate is
who America is sliding apart we don't
know which future to strive for we get
these answers from this this underlying
story which I refer to as a society's
Master narrative that's that story that
gives meaning to everything and and lets
you know what is true or not why you
belong together what you should strive
for and we've had these changes I've
studied these changes of the past
Millennium and also further back and we
when we get into these these deep Master
narrative transitions it's really really
hard on the human psyche when we lose
that narrative we turn on each other we
get desponding we have anxiety we feel
terrible and we lose faith in the future
but then every other time until now
we've always succeeded we've always
gotten out of it and we found a new
story and now we seem to be
transitioning into something that is
perhaps a form of datest Master
narrative and if we succeed with this
and we make it to the fourth Industrial
Revolution and we're able to unite and
around this new narrative then we could
face a new golden age the future could
be very fantastic but when we're in
these transitions it's a lot more easy
to spot what could go terribly terribly
wrong instead what was that study about
the Norwegian generational happiness
switch Yeah uh so um we've Norwegians uh
this this Norwegian Serv called
Norwegian monitor they've been uh
serving happiness since 1985 and Young
young people have always been uh the
happiest and old people have always been
the least happy which makes sense
happiness is a reward you get when you
succeed with reaching adaptive relevant
goals which young people have tons of
and when you're old you kind of don't
have these goals anymore so uh you would
expect your happiness to go down and
what's happened in the last uh since
2009 is that you had this incredibly
sharp decline for the youngest and then
for the also for the middle-aged and
this uh this this weak rise in happiness
and and quite strong rise and
satisfaction for the oldest generation
for your tired people so the impression
we get from talking to them is just that
young people are becoming miserable and
losing fate in the future they don't
think they will have good lives there's
so much so many so many uh threats
coming up while the old people are
realizing that they just timed their
right life really well so they have this
new found gratitude they see that all
right I might have 10 15 20 years left
to live and that'll probably be okay the
biggest changes won't come until after
that so just have this this yeah an
amplified sense of having had a great
life and that they should be grateful
for now getting out in time and and
having been with this post World War II
boom of economic Prosperity where life
just got better and better and better
and now when it seems to turn they're uh
they're ready to check out in not too
long and and this they feel bad about
their their children and especially
grandchildren they feel really bad about
them but that doesn't seem to affect
them quality of life it just makes them
more appreciative of their own lives oh
wow yeah because you would think as
grandchildren optimizing machines you
would have presumed that the impending
uncertainty about the future of our
grandchildren could have negatively
impacted our subjective well-being but
it seems like that's not the case it
seems like what what they say to us is
that they sometimes stay awake at night
cuz they feel so bad about their grand
children and they're a little bit
surprised and have a little bit bad
conscience for it but it doesn't reduce
their quality of life so yeah they just
they get this this a much stronger sense
of satisfaction and a somewhat stronger
sense of Happiness from from now seeing
how future generation will struggle
while they will not Christ okay so do
you do you believe that uh comparing
yourself to the generation that came
before you and your level of success or
well-being is is that a big determinant
of well-being yeah uh you have to
separate a little bit different aspects
of well-being we we concept like
well-being plus meaning happiness plus
meaning equals well-being so happiness
is this solving uh adaptive relevant
problem for yourself as an individual
and that is inherently relative you have
a comparison group and if you're doing
better than your comparison group you
experience a sense of Happiness
temporarily and if you divorce you have
a temporar sense of of uh of unhappiness
so uh that's one of the reasons why
social media is has been so destructive
We Believe for young people's happiness
because it's just exploded their
comparison group before you compared
yourself to your par in your local
community now you compare yourself to
the Kardashians and people that fly
private jets on YouTube and suddenly
your life is not that great anymore
relatively so yeah happiness is an
inherently relative assessment yeah the
what's that quote comparison is the
thief of Joy it seems like it's actually
the under comparison is the underpinning
of happiness or
dissatisfaction yeah no so if if you uh
that's one of the reasons why altruism
and and doing voluntary work working
with refugees or people are worse off
that has a strong effect also on your
happiness it reminds you just how far
you could have fallen and you're not
yeah it it recalibrates your comparison
group in a in a in a beneficial way wow
so a good intervention for well-being is
to remind yourselves of of just how the
Myriad of different ways that things
could have gone wrong or all of the
people from your past that had things
that weren't as good as you I mean
there's that there's that famous uh it's
either Aristotle or Aurelius that says
um uh the things that you now take for
granted were ones that you once only
wished of having right that in the past
in the past you only wanted to have this
thing and today you walk past it without
even looking at it twice
um it's it's the same thing with mating
ideologies all of these mating
ideologies come with a Utopia that we
think if we can just get this Utopia
it's going to be amazing and then when
we finally get the mating AEL implement
the Utopia we discover things like life
love doesn't last forever being a
stay-at-home mom is in Paradise so yeah
we keep striving for it we make a better
and better society and once we get it we
accustomed to it and we come up with new
Utopias I had this idea for a little
while uh reflecting on my own life
especially in my 20s when I started
getting into self-development and
personal growth
that I was able to ameliorate my own
feelings of insufficiency as long as I
was doing personal growth and
self-development because I think the the
subtext of what it taught me was I might
not feel like I'm worthy enough right
now but if I'm half a percent better
tomorrow maybe tomorrow is actually the
day when I will finally and if you just
continue to keep yourself on this
hamster wheel it kind of it's a Salve
right it kind of papers over the cracks
of perhaps deeper issues that you need
to deal with like I don't have a good
sleep and wake pattern or I'm not I
don't have people around me that I can
talk to or whatever the reason is that
you're dissatisfied with life but yeah I
I see in a lot of the self-development
community people using the promise of a
better tomorrow as a
um a plaster
that are a Band-Aid that they can place
over the feelings of insufficiency that
they have today yeah well theoretically
uh the optimal recipe for a happy life
is that you should start out as low in
society as you can without being
traumatized by it and then make gradual
Pro progress throughout your life and
reach as high as you can because as long
as you keep doing better than you used
to you get this happiness reward so if
you want objective success being born at
the top of society is the best but if
your parents are beautiful successful
millionaires you probably won't be and
and that you're not going to be happy so
so there's something to getting that
even progress and then in addition to
that you need a couple of crises that
you take yourself out of through your
own resources okay yeah I mean so much
so much interesting stuff there first
off um I have a lot of friends who are
self-made successes millionaire as one
billionaire uh and I asked them both
about their intentions for their
children because I know that what they
valued during their upbringing was very
heavily their uh the challenges they had
to overcome you know this sort of
working class grit spit and sawdust
mentality but if they do that to their
children what the was the point of
working this hard in any case to not
give them the benefits of the the
resources and and and the livelihood you
worked so hard to be able to afford them
but then if you give it to them you're
condemning them to a life of inferiority
unless you're going to have like
multi-generational self-made
billionaires like that's also pretty
unlikely so that's tough um Eddie Hearn
the famous boxing promoter from the UK
said he beautifully conceptualized this
and he said uh his dad made his father
made the the boxing organization that
he's a part of and his father had had an
awful lot of success and then Eddie came
came in and took it to new heights made
it bigger than 10 100 times bigger than
it ever was and did all the rest of the
things and somebody asked like if you
could go back and change anything uh
what would you change uh and he said I
never got to do it first but it always
felt like he was living in his father's
shadow that the New Frontier was never
broken by Eddie it was always broken by
his his father and uh he he it's evident
that he lives with this pain
of the the echo of it I mean dude the
drummer from Mega Death you know
the story of Metallica so originally
Metallica's drummer got kicked out or
left the B I think he got kicked out of
the band so he decides to go and start a
new band called Mega Death Meade goes on
to be one of probably the top 10 metal
bands in history but they're not
Metallica and in interview this
interview my housemate sites all the
time this guy still with you know one of
the most successful metal bands in
history always has this gap between what
he could have been and and what he was
so yeah it's very much not an objective
assessment of our position it's very
much a relative assessment of our of our
predicament I also had this idea kind of
plays off the back of this that one
potential strategy that you can go
through or that would be maybe adaptive
is let's say there are ceilings to the
level of status and resources and
declaim and whatever that you're going
to reach in life like there is only one
richest guy on the planet right and once
you hit that there is no further to go
so it is kind of a zero some game in
terms of the rank order in some regard
and presuming that you're going to reach
ASM toote right and top out at some
point I wonder whether there is an
argument to be made that actually
stretching out the progression and the
development of your material acquisition
like uh winning the lottery could be one
of the worst things that could ever
happen to you because it's such a huge
step change it's like all right and now
how am I like how slow is the
development from this new couple of
million dollar that I previously never
had wealth going to be as oppos as
opposed to if you were able to you know
regularly and consistently move 5% per
year toward whatever the end Financial
goal is so yeah it made me think about
how uh people that achieve rapid success
may end up it's called gold medal
syndrome uh from Olympians right it's
like I finally did the thing
now what and I wonder whether yeah I
wonder whether there's an equivalent for
slow life strategy well well there there
the good news is that there's this other
source of well-being I we conceptualize
well-being is happiness plus meaning
equals well-being so happiness is what
you can succeed as an individual meaning
is what you do for your community what
you do for other people so when you see
that very successful business people
when they get to a certain point in
their life with success they start
becoming philanthropist they start doing
charity they start working for others
and happiness is limited there are
limits to how happy you can be how much
well-being you can get out of that but
there seems to be no limits to how much
well-being you can get from working for
others that meaning part of the equation
can potentially be a lot lot higher you
can for instance see with uh suicide
bombers and
revolutionaries that they are they
derive so much meaning for working for a
cause and ideals that they believe in
that they're willing to SA acfic your
own life this is called the devoted
actor Theory within evolutionary
psychology so that is when this meaning
Quest becomes pathological so what
you're thinking instead of of of spacing
your billions out through life at some
point when you have enough
individualistic success start working
for other people start making other
people feel better then you will get a
sense of meaning one thing is you'll get
more happiness from recalibrating your
comparison group but you'll get this
satisfaction that has has number one it
can be a lot more intense than happiness
potentially but also it's more enduring
happiness is a temporary reward it goes
up and then it goes down meaning seems
to accumulate over a lifetime so as
people get older once they've had enough
individual success if they want to keep
flourishing and feeling well then
working for the good of others it's it's
a very beneficial strategy depends a
little bit on your personality but most
people benefit a lot from working for
others Matts I've been enthralled today
this is been absolutely fantastic we met
each other at HB what 5 months ago six
month four months ago something like
that been very much looking forward to
this this absolutely completely
delivered so much new stuff that I've
never learned before I really really
appreciate the Insight let's run this
back man let's find more things that we
need to talk about I really really
enjoyed it where should people go they
want to keep up to date with you and the
work that you do where should you send
them on the
Internet uh I have nowhere to send them
right now maybe you can uh place that uh
polygon article I wrote In
in the description under the video and
then I'm work I'm working on two books
uh I have completed one that I'm hoping
to get published soon and then I'm
finishing up another one on this history
of mating I have one chapter left to
right and then I will submit that to
publisher so hopefully at some point in
the future I will have some books to
offer and and I would very much like for
people to read those but at the moment
yeah they can also go to Google Scholar
and and and put my name there and and
they'll get up a bunch of articles that
I've written mate when you are ready to
publish that book it's going to do
unbelievably well I love I love these
insights thank you very much again for
your time and I'm looking forward to
speaking to you next time thank you so
much Chris it's been wonderful I really
enjoyed it thank you if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe